it dawns on me that the build-up is now
over there's gonna be the last video
featuring the Star Wars curtain cape for
a little while but this is to be the
beginning of a hiatus we're gonna
celebrate it with spoilers that's does
nothing but stone walls know them what's
to lose
spoiler tuck yeah that's a fair warning
right there this is spoiler talk for
Star Wars The Force awakens if you have
not seen Star Wars The Force awakens yet
it's okay I have a spoiler free review
you can check that out don't watch this
in fact don't read comment sections
either alright warnings over now we're
gonna talk about some Star Wars The
Force awakens spoiler should I saw the
movie for a second time last night and I
loved it even more the Star Wars The
Force awakens starts out the opening
crawl literally says Luke Skywalker is
missing I was like what wait a minute
but it'd be he maybe is kylo Ren got a
coincidental that Luke Skywalker
disappears when kylo Ren steps on with
the same that's not the case though
you'll find that out later but this
movie started out how he wanted to start
out it was just there's a little bit of
dialogue and Poe gets that thing from
Max von Sydow
and then boom here comes the first-order
with kylo Ren I love that scene when Poe
has the gun he shoots kylo Ren kylo Ren
just like BAM just stops that both just
midair that's what I loved about the
force in this movie they used the force
in familiar ways but just updated it
like when kylo Ren freezes rey in her
place it's like this weird unnatural do
she just goes but and she's just like
frozen right there you see like she's
shaking I was like that looks like she
was stopped with the forest but this is
the beginning of all the familiar stuff
like right out the gate the little droid
the bb-8 droid has a bit of information
the baddies need so they need to get the
droid to the resistance I was like Star
Wars the original but did you see that
laser ball get stopped in midair because
that was right and one of the things I
loved was Poe and Finn Poe and Finn just
naturally gravitated towards each other
they just felt like best friends right
out the game Finn doesn't want to be a
part of the first order he needs a pilot
to get out of there who's a captive it
happens to be the best pilot in the
resistance and you really do feel that
like that one tracking shot would just
shows Poe wiping out all those Tie
Fighters you're like they say this guy's
the best pilot but he is just the best
pilot I love it when a movie says
something about a character and you
clearly see you're like yeah no one's
disputing that there in the cockpit he's
like good to meet you Poe
good to meet you too Finn after I saw
the movie the second I was telling my
friends was like in four minutes they
established this Brotherhood of
friendship between these two characters
the prequels couldn't do that in six
hours their friendship was just done
really well I'm looking forward to
seeing that friendship grow in the next
movie so we meet up with Ray and Ray's a
scavenger she meets up with Finn and
then they get off of jakku on the
Millennium Falcon like when she was like
that ships garbage I was like I think I
know a ship you're talking about and
don't call it garbage but it was when
the gun on the Millennium Falcon locked
and she flipped it around and then they
wasted the TIE fighter to the line how
did you do that she's like I don't know
I just I just don't know how I did it I
was like are they both Jedi in this
movie and she starts getting visions she
touches the lightsabers he's the whole
backstory of kylo Ren I was like wait a
minute there has been nothing in this
movie to show that finn is in tune with
the force at all oh my gosh our girl
here is actually going to be the jedi
pinball a badass shot with a blaster is
not he's not dude with the force let's
talk about kylo Ren for a second now
before the movie came out every was like
kylo Ren some people speculated that
he's just going to ease this huge badass
Sith Lord here to take charge and do
what Vader wouldn't then you find out
and pretty on the nose way the leader of
the first order of this guy named Snoke
talks to kylo Ren via hologram when I
first saw him I was kind of disappointed
you look like a big 50-foot tall monster
but since it's a hologram I imagine he's
more along the lines of normal size but
he tells kylo Ren he's like your father
han solo's with them so don't get bold
to the light side but we know nothing
about snook we don't know where he comes
from we don't know who he is we don't
know how he seduced Ben solo to the dark
side we just don't know anything about
it any circus says this dude is old he's
like this guy's old like he has seen
some [ __ ] oh we're talking he probably
hung out with Yoda he does have history
on his face I love the fact you just
look at this dude's face you're like you
have a huge scar going that way and it's
going that way or that way or however it
is there's a story on your face buddy
and you pissed someone off and as
someone had a lightsaber they see what
kylo Ren has right and then takes off
his helmet I was like at first I was
disappointed so I thought this dude was
gonna be awesome maybe he's gonna add
likes cards fucked-up face but he didn't
he just looked like a guy not just a guy
didn't look like a menacing guy he
looked like an average guy and that did
disappoint me at first but then as you
start marinating on it and as the
he goes on and Adam driver does a great
job as kylo Ren without the mask I was
like no I like that
this dude is what I wanted to see with
Anakin Skywalker but never saw that's
right he's Anakin 2.0 of sorts I mean
looking at the Anakin parallel it really
is the same thing his Jedi Master
trained him he turned bad he wiped out
all the other Jedi his Jedi Master goes
into hiding and he's one of the hammer
fists of the Galactic [ __ ] trying to
just ruin everything for everybody
then this new apprentice will come along
and be trained by the master who trained
the guy who turned bad so the wrong can
be righted but I love that we see
through his [ __ ] in this movie I mean
alright look at kylo ren's world for him
and the people around him he's the only
space wizard out there he's taking out
all the competition Luke Skywalker has
gone into hiding so he has this big
scary lightsaber everyone in the first
order is like a little [ __ ] mob he's
gonna rage out on his computer everyone
takes that at face value and he really
hasn't had anyone oppose him because he
is the only space wizard out there so
then Rey comes along and you see that
she is actually in tune with the force
and when he's like reading her mind she
starts fighting back with them and he's
just like oh [ __ ] what is this this is
the first time he's felt this in quite
some time probably the first time he has
ever felt it as he has been kylo Ren
she's like you're just scared you're not
gonna live up to Darth Vader and he just
snaps back he's like oh he's like takes
a breather and you see right there it's
like yeah the disappointment with kylo
Ren for a lot of people was that he
wasn't this big menacing guy I mean he
was at the beginning but by the end he
was just an average dude but he was
always an average dude he was just
peacocking the entire time he's just
puffing his chest look boom so rad and
it was just all a bluff he's actually
not as badass as he made people around
like he is but as for his fall with
Anakin Skywalker there was no family
dynamic with him where there was the
master apprentice dynamic but you still
have that with Luke Skywalker and you
clearly see that Luke Skywalker is
ashamed as well so what I liked about it
we with obi-wan Kenobi hiding you kind
of got the feeling he was looking after
Luke Skywalker Yoda and the prequels
just said he's like I'm gonna go in
exile I failed but the emotional impact
was I just kind of felt like was that a
Jedi thing do you just go into hiding
because what was Luke Skywalker I felt
like he went into hiding because he was
ashamed he could not look his friends in
the eyes with that feeling of yeah I
failed you all I failed your son and I
ripped your family apart I can't look at
you and it was just a bit more sad for
me also with the family
Anakin Skywalker there are no parents to
see their son go to the dark side of me
he had no father and then his mother
died while he was rescuing her but in
this movie you saw that the solos had to
deal with the fact that their son became
a murderous [ __ ] that impacted them
in very strong and powerful ways and you
see that kylo ren's bit of a religious
nut somehow he's been convinced that the
burned up Darth Vader helmet is some
relic that brings him closer to his
grandfather but it's just a burned mask
what this dude prays to this thing he's
losing his mind
and he's doing nothing for him it's just
an artifact you get the feeling Stokes
lucknow totally your grandfather would
have wanted this and he was a great
person and yeah he prayed it was burned
up mask and with kylo Ren you feel like
he's in the larval stage you see Darth
Vader had been an [ __ ] for about 20
years by the time we really saw him in
the original Star Wars kylo Ren has been
an [ __ ] for an undisclosed amount of
time you get the feeling it's not a long
time so we've only begun to see what
kylo Ren can do I think in the next
movie he's going to be much more badass
than the next one much more harmony he's
just going to progress this is the tip
of the iceberg for him and that's
another thing like with the characters
that kind of disappointed Mill's I
didn't see a lot of Poe and I didn't see
anything of Captain phasma I couldn't
say in my spoiler free review it was
like oh we're going to see them in the
sequels because if I say that then you
know they lived through this movie yeah
all those characters phasma poe kylo Ren
were they carried over and I love that
too I love the fact they didn't just go
through baddies in this movie knowing
that they're gonna have new batteries in
the next one it's like no the baddies in
this saga are going to carry into the
next movies because that's how it should
go you shouldn't just change out your
bad guys for the sake of making action
figures keep the bad guys around for the
entire trilogy man just makes it more
interesting then the biggest tragedy in
the entire third this was one of the
this was my least favorite thing in the
entire movie but that's just because
it's a personal thing with me has
nothing to do with the construction of
this movie but oh my god the Han Solo
saying he goes and confronts his son Ben
and right when he was I was like han
Solo is going to die
this is [ __ ] sure enough he talks to
him it's great conversation and it's I
also love the layest like I don't want
to forget him I want him back so can you
please go talk to him and she ultimately
sent some solder to his death I get that
Harrison Ford didn't want to do another
one so it's just you might as well kill
him all for the sake of story but what
made it more tragic is after kylo Ren
takes his lightsaber and thrusts it
through his father
it was Chewbacca scream that really made
it tragic for
me the way Chewbacca reacted to this I
really felt like Chewbacca saw his best
friend or brother getting murdered right
in front of him and it freaked me out it
was just too real and even when Han soul
was falling he grazes Ben Ben solos face
because he's still his bully and then
you're like okay kylo Ren you're not
you're just a gnat you're a dick now and
then the lightsaber fight comes and he's
always like he's beating his chest and
shig is like Chewie shot him and so he's
bleeding and he keeps pounding his
side's to get the pain going to get the
anger going to feel him cuz that's how
darkside people think and Finn's
fighting him because you knew Finn was
going to fight him and you Finn gets his
ass kicked ultimately like I said my
spoiler free review what I love about
this fight is that it's not
choreographed it's not super flashy it's
really dirty me trees are getting
slashed around him it's just this
fighting for survival I mean fing gets
ox sliced up his spine drop I thought he
was dead but he's not dead he's in the
medical Bay so he's probably gonna have
some prosthetic spine in the next movie
cuz that was bad news
he took a solid hit to the lightsabers
in the snow this is the oh [ __ ] moment
in my review I was like there was a
moment where I welled up and I was like
that is amazing
it's this scene right here kylo ren's
using the force getting the lightsabers
going to him you really should come on
and it snaps out of the snow goes right
past his head and then Rey just goes BAM
and catches it in the air and I was like
ah I'm pre-ordering your hot toy right
now right and then the force theme
swells up she busts out that lightsaber
blade and those two go at it in their
lightsaber fight they clash and he's
like you need a teacher I can show you
the ways of the force and she's like the
force and then she quiets her mind and
then the swelling of the music and she
calls herself and then she's just ready
to go and she bests him she gets she
beats him she'd I believe she cut off a
limb but I first thought I was like
you're pretty sure he lost a hand but I
saw the second time I was like but he's
kind of slice and plops on the ground I
know he has a sweet scar down his face
which again this made sense to me some
people were like I can't believe this
girl who's never held lies ever in her
life beat the guy who did but think
about it kylo Ren is extremely out of
practice he has not gone up against
anyone with the lightsaber since he
ultimately turned bad in the meantime
he's just kind of intimidating everybody
cutting down old guys and raging out on
his macbook computer screen when he gets
really pissed he has had no practice he
has had no come
tition he has had no one to actually
have a lightsaber fight with so this
dude is rusty and when this girl kind of
gets in tune with the forest which does
give her an edge that finn didn't have
because he's not in tune with the forest
and then she beats the [ __ ] out of him
you get the feeling snook when you turn
in to the dark side didn't train him
with a lightsaber or anything like that
didn't train him to be better he's like
alright now your batter I go dude that
stuff that you need to do and whatever
you'll be efficient for now and then I'm
probably going to discard you when I'm
done with it so this girl beats him and
smokes like bring kylo Ren to me it's
time to complete his training again with
the next movie he's going to be more
badass than he was in this movie and
then Rey goes off she has the map she
finds Luke Skywalker on this little
island supposedly it's the first giant
empal which also is funny when I saw a
second time I noticed it when kylo Ren
was reading her mind when he had her
captive he was like I see it the island
with the ocean and at the end of the
movie she goes to an island in the
middle of an ocean which almost implies
like has she been there before was she
just seeing the future because she saw a
part of the map I don't know again this
movie is really open to interpretation
but when she found Luke Skywalker she
held out the lightsaber I thought Luke
was gonna walk over to her and be like
the force is strong in my family my
father has it
I have it my sister has it you have that
power too
Oh family it's his daughter biggest
theory about that right now is that she
is Luke Skywalker's daughter but I don't
know why Luke would have dropped her off
I'm Jack ku because we don't really know
when kylo Ren turned bad it's like
what's the chronology of events how old
is kylo Ren to read would you get him
bringing in new characters I think the
next movie would be a great time to
bring in Lando Calrissian Lando can come
in and be like my best friend was
murdered I'm going to avenge him I'm
gonna kill the one who killed my friend
but does he avenge his friend by killing
his son or does he honor his friend by
trying to bring his son back he gets
that which I know it's like if his
father couldn't do it how and how can
Lando do it yeah I know I'm just
spitballing here man guys in the end
star wars the force awakens was a great
movie when I first saw it and it was an
even better movie the second time I saw
it it's a great character movie it's a
great family tragedy it's a great space
opera and Star Wars is back I'm super
glad I'm just here to see that alright
so again the force awakens have you seen
it what did you think about it spoilers
in the comments section go nuts you have
the green light to do so but as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more
click right here to see more